Incremental planning is based on the idea that requirements are recorded
on story cards, sort of use cases or scenarios that the customer
provides. So the first step in incremental planning is to select
user stories for a given release, and which stories exactly to include
depends on the time available and on the priority. For example,
scenarios that we might want to realize right away because they are
particular important for the customer. After we select user stories for
the release, we break stories i to tasks. So what we do,
we take the user stories and we identify specific development tasks
that we need to perform in order to realize these stories. Once
we know our tasks, we can plan our release. And at
that point, we can develop, integrate and test our code. And of
course, this is more kind of an iterative process right here,
so we do this many times. When we're ready, when we accomplish
all of our tasks, all of our tests pass and we're happy,
we release this software. At the point, the released software is evaluated
by us, by the customer, and we can reiterate. We can
continue the process, select more stories and continue it this way.